[Music]
so the
once monthly meeting to discuss finances
i want to hear more about this
yeah what's the format okay before so
you and i talked on our last podcast
about
checking in and you had some great
suggestions for some questions and
we've used those and adapted those for
our own relationship
it's one thing to do a relationship
check-in yep i also think another really
valuable check-in is a financial
check-in
and so the way that we do it is we
have a spreadsheet that we've built
it's custom for us based on what we
what's important to us so we have our
expenses that are in there
in the course of a 30 minute call
we will look over our expenses and the
call by the way is with a third party
who kind of walks us through some of the
the numbers the expenses take five
minutes
because really most of our expenses are
planned for okay i'll give you an
example except for your handbags
except for the handbags that's right
well those are going to be an incoming
gift from
tim ferriss soon enough my my private
label handbag line
i can't believe you've told the world
that's right so
here's the thing i think about expenses
i think most people they spend time
all their time looking at expenses and
it's really depressing
yeah this is the wrong place to spend a
lot of time
what we did instead was we said okay our
groceries are basically the same
every single month our whatever rent is
basically the same
every single month there's a couple
areas that are variable
so we actually sat down at the end of
the year and we planned out
how many trips do we want to take how
much is each of those trips
and we kind of got we got pretty
granular about it
we also know that some surprise expenses
come up with things like
gifts so we planned it out appropriately
ahead of time this is how many people
we're gonna give gifts to this is the
amount we're gonna gift
charity same thing and so those are
baked in so on a given month
yeah we might be a little bit over on
food we might be a little bit under on
gas but it's basically within parameters
okay after five minutes of that we spend
way more time looking at our rich life
goals
so we have about five rich life goals
that are
actively being saved for that would be
like the 10-year wedding anniversary
and so each quarter each month or
quarter we have money going into those
goals
and then we have a backlog you can never
have too many rich life goals
because at some point we're gonna hit
one of those goals
what's next guess what we got our
backlog ready to go
and so that backlog could be you know
hiring somebody to do xyz for us
it could be taking this special trip
buying a new car
this type of specific car and model it's
all there
what would be your true but
most embarrassing backlog rich life goal
to share on this podcast right now
oh my god um
this is horrifying let me think
okay well my okay so once i sat down and
i asked my friends i was like
what is what is the next level for you
the rich life next level
and so one of them was like i want to
jet and one of them was like i want to
take a trip to tahiti or something like
that and mine was uh
i never want to have to pack a suitcase
again in my life
and they're like are you stupid that's
like 50 bucks
but okay i'll tell you what it is now
the suitcase part
i don't want to have to carry luggage
when i travel
okay that and that's relatively
inexpensive you can ship it for like 100
bucks
i don't i just don't want to i want to
walk out of an airplane
free and not sweating because i have a
like a bag that i'm carrying around with
me that was a very
i don't know it feels a little indulgent
to me but it's like a hundred bucks
okay so so shipping luggage as opposed
to transporting luggage
correct yeah i know i know a few people
who've
done that for many many years they
refuse
they refuse i know one also who hates to
select clothing to travel with so
is a he wears black shirt tan
cargo pants uh every day kind of steve
jobs
with uh like a limp biscuit twist to it
and
and uh same shoes and so his
assistant will pack i guess they're
gallon ziploc bags or something like
that
with each day's outfit because he hates
doing laundry also so he just has
all of these versions of the same outfit
and so if he's going on like a 10-day
trip
there'll be 10 gallon ziploc bags
with each day's outfit this is not what
i thought was going to be his rich life
but god bless you i mean all the best
that's why it's his rich life for me
all right okay so that so that's what we
do so we um we start off with the
expenses like five minutes
we spend more time on the rich life
goals and then we have
an open backlog of questions you know
there's sometimes things like
hey we've got this trip coming up like
do we want to stay here there or like
should we get this or that things like
that
we have a document a running document
that we just track these questions on
and usually within 30 sometimes 60
minutes we're good to go for about a
month that's
roughly the structure i would encourage
it for anybody and i want to add a twist
for people
when you do these meetings it can be
really depressing
because talking about money for most
people is really negative why did you
spend this much we don't want that at
all we want this to be a positive
experience
so i would encourage if possible you
know go out to dinner
or if you have children and you have the
ability to maybe get some help for
one hour two hours take advantage of
that
this is supposed to be a positive
experience where you can say you know
what
i really want to talk about money in a
way that benefits both of us
and i would love to get your input what
can we do to make this a
great environment for us to have this
conversation do that
and you're going to be way more set than
having it with
dinner on the table and people screaming
that's not going to be conducive to this
type of meeting
you